vector like this okay we'll just call
this vector a and you have another
vector let's just say it's like this
vector B and you want to add these
together what you can do is you can take
with the vectors you can slide them left
and right up and down you just don't
want to make the vectors longer and you
don't want to change the angle of the
vector because then it would be a
different vector because the vector has
a length and direction so magnitude and
direction but what you want to do is you
want to take these vectors and you want
to put them in such a way that where one
vector ends the other vector begins okay
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
slide this vector over here okay keep
the angle the same keep the length the
same okay there is vector B so the
specter terminates here the other vector
initiates here and terminates there so
the end result of those two vectors
being added together is this vector
right here a plus B that's the resultant
vector of adding them together so it's
kind of like if you were to walk this
direction and then walk this direction
the end result is you could have cut
through the backyards of your friends
and gotten there a little bit quicker
okay now if you subtract vectors okay
when you subtract the vector what it
means is that the vector is going 180
degrees the opposite direction so this
vector here would be negative B same
length 180 degrees opposite it's
pointing the opposite direction that's a
negative B and so now if we wanted to do
this again let's do a minus B this time
okay a minus B so vector a is here
negative B is going this direction now
okay negative B a where one ends the
other one begins and so our end result
is that vector right there a minus B
that's what they call the resultant
vector so this has been a little bit
about
how to work with the vectors just just
with the drawing it's okay now let's
look at that algebra part of it how do
you add subtract and multiply vectors
well all you have to do is add the X
components and add the Y components or
subtract the X components subtract the Y
component so if we want to find out what
u plus V okay is in this example we just
take 3 plus negative 4 and 1 plus 2 so
I'm just adding the X's and I'm just
adding the Y's and that's gonna give us
negative 1/3 so that's the end result
and if you want to see what it looks
like over here in the plane we've got 3
1 okay so that's vector u okay and
vector V is negative 4 - okay so we're
left 4 up to and that's vector V and so
now what we're gonna do is we're going
to the end result is negative 1 3 so
it's negative 1 3 okay right there
that's the end result now remember you
can take these vectors you can slide
them left and right
up and down you just want to rotate them
or make them longer so if I shift this
over and shift it up
see there's vector U okay where one
terminates the other one begins and you
can see the end result is this diagonal
here same thing with vector V you could
shift vector V over here okay and the
diagonal is the end result of adding
those two vectors together ok now if you
subtract them same thing u minus V
that's going to be 3 minus negative 4
and 1 minus 2 which is 7 and negative 1
and then the last thing I'll show you is
that let's say you want to multiply by a
scalar like they call the scalar
multiplication 3 times u all you have to
do is multiply the X and the y
components by 3 so it's just like doing
the distributive
property so the vector will be nine
comma three and you can see the specter
is just going to be three times longer
so if this is vector u it's just going
to be nine three four five six seven
eight nine three it's going to go in the
same direction but you can see it's one
two three times longer so this has been
a about adding and subtracting vectors
I'll see you in the next video